hey guys welcome back to the woodland
podcast i'm james marshall and thanks
for tuning in to another episode very
much appreciated or if this is your
first time well then welcome to the show
and there is plenty of great lad stories
for you to scroll back through the
archives and get your ears around but
this episode is brought to you by
reminder sports who make some of the
coolest sports care out and they've been
working behind the scenes on a woodland
basketball singlet for the summer which
will feature some of the waterland
legends who have come on the podcast
already so stay tuned around that space
make sure you're following the wallet
instagram page if you're not already to
stay right on
but anyway i have an absolute legend of
a lad for you for this episode so let's
get to it
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a lad well today i'm stoked to be
in the presence of arguably the greatest
pound-for-pound lad in the game he's a
fan favorite for good reason as his
ability to dominate at the highest level
despite his size as impressive to watch
he firstly starred with waikato in his
early years before carrying the chiefs
over the last few and now he's a very
key member of this all black squad he's
also just recently signed with suntor in
japan which i'm really looking forward
to hearing all about it is one of the
greatest lads around it is damien
mckenzie welcome mate thanks mate thanks
for the kind introduction very kind
words right you're an absolute wizard so
i'm stoked to have you on but firstly
let's start with the big signing move to
suntory how did that all come about yeah
it's um
i guess i was sort of looking last year
about like different i was off contract
so just looking at opportunities um
offshore and just seeing what was what
was out there and
uh there was a couple other clubs who
was uh i looked dead and then um
obviously beauty had been at suntory so
gotta talk to him about it and yeah just
thought it was a good chance to to come
over um
i'd be lying to seth like the money
wasn't good um it was so it's an
opportunity to
benefit that way but also just to you
know just like something fresh hopefully
you know obviously playing super for a
while now so something maybe less
physical and yeah it's uh it's here now
so
looking forward to it's gonna be fun
mate you're gonna kill it over there
that style absolutely suits the way you
play yeah like it's just so fast high
tempo footy so the rugby's not for
everyone over there but i think you're
gonna
absolutely thrive over there yeah it's
gonna it's it's obviously they
play a bit of an attacking brand and
everyone's probably a bit more my size
over here so which is gonna help as well
um and then we've got some great lads at
the club as well which is which is great
good for you aussie boys
tom sanders is just signed there too
which is awesome
um so yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
fun the afternoon rugby a lot of the
time which is awesome too and
uh yeah as we start i think the first
match is in
might be the six of jam maybe so
yeah it's going to come around quick
right do you feel any pressure coming in
filling in uh bodhi's boots and
obviously taking his contract plus
something it's definitely not his
contract definitely not
definitely not plus some but um
not so much obviously buddy's a great
player um
you know so being able to i guess chat
to him about what it was like playing
over here has been great and i think for
me it's i think like you said i think
it's a game style that
um suits the way i play so i'm looking
forward to getting out and just you know
try and play that attacking rugby and um
yeah just trying to add my sort of spice
to the to the team and what i can do so
uh yeah it's hard boots to fill um
knowing vodi's been here that's gonna be
fun i've got some good guys around me to
play with so
hopefully leave a good stake in the
ground and yeah place to play some good
rugby mate no doubt so you're only there
for this season and then you're back to
new zealand rugby is that how the
contract works yeah yeah i'm just here
for the one season so sort of be back in
um roughly may-ish around that sort of
time and then
yeah i'll obviously sign back with new
zealand rugby and then play miter team
for
for the first while because i'm not
eligible to play straight away for the
all blacks and this is an injury which
yeah so obviously i'm gonna have to play
good rugby over here though first to be
considered and that's scored so i mean
again i'll come back and i'll just play
for
mighty strong arm who had a great year
this year and yeah the provincial rank
is
um fun maybe to play another
level rugby actually missed playing in
the last two games last year playing
with some of the most enjoyable rugby i
played so
yeah that's the plan and um yeah we back
definitely back to the one only chiefs
as well nice mate you're gonna be deadly
in that strong arm team they went a
little bit too good this year didn't
they they were good late they got a good
young side and um a couple of holders
you've still got hunger floating around
and yeah um but they went really well uh
they're a good side and
um
yeah that's uh yeah like i said it'll be
cool to be able to get back and play
some rugby for them yeah mate this side
sort of reminds me a little bit about
the side um maybe four or five years ago
when you and anton leonard brown and
weber and stuff were all coming through
all young they're exciting players and
they've got they've got that again now
yeah they do it's um
we were lucky enough when we started out
we cut my old heads we was a bit older
than us but then a few young guys coming
through which was great which was great
like we were one of those teams where
you know some weekends we'd come out and
couldn't play the best rugby ever and b
a lot of teams within your sun weekends
are obviously experienced somehow played
a role there's one yeah i remember one
game particularly where
cutler grump from taranaki did did some
did a few things to us i'm sure marty's
probably put that told you that story um
but yeah we had an exciting team it's
like they got now very very youthful and
a bit of experience too and i just
play exciting brand rugby it's good to
watch give us a little bit more about
the grubs from taranaki is this when uh
you didn't talk to swano for a few weeks
was it after that game what did he do he
must have been filthy yeah it was um it
was my first year and
i mean um yeah we went down to taranaki
and uh we gotta go to hiding actually i
think there's something like 40 or 50
something to know and
like i'm all for like you know yeah your
small talk and stuff and but
particularly
yeah one occasion
it's just manhattan next thing i just
think clocked into here not what's going
on here and i thought it might have been
someone else and so anyway it's anybody
and i jump up
so what are you doing lately he's like i
wasn't even me i was like
so you're pathetic and then
it was over you and you could watch you
get cropped bakers he was he was playing
for them and he's one of you
he's probably a bit better now you know
top grabs you'll play against yeah yeah
yeah angus tavio he always reminds me of
it and i remember
after that game
my love for the neck he was but he
wasn't much you know
and then yeah i didn't i was pretty
pretty sour after the game and probably
wasn't till two weeks later until she
might have to go up for an operation
let's see i'll get a touch base just in
case
something bad happens so yeah but yeah
and yeah it wasn't i don't know if
mother david's too happy probably quite
embarrassing for them was chucking the
ball up marty when he was on the ground
yeah uh
yeah
i'm not sure if you had a scenario with
tojo but yeah it's um that rivalry
between your brother's eye it's always
there all right hundred percent and
anyway let's get back to japan thing so
what's your living situation there are
you just in like an apartment have you
pretty much walked into your apartment
no no he was in the penthouse
um
so i'm not man
i'm just in a yeah i'm currently in my
queue so got in on tuesday and straight
to
off the plane into my queue i've got two
weeks in this room hotel room where i
can't can't leave the room the window
does open which is nice and then
i've got a what bike in here is a wee
night show not night light show out here
on every night which is um good for good
for head space just yeah sit down look
at that for during the night and um
yeah and then when i get out yesterday
out in two weeks time and i've got a
two-bedroom apartment so most of the
boys live in this one big apartment
block um so i'll move in there and
i think it's quite close to training and
yeah it'll be good to just be myself
sort of locking it down and
living the dream
absolutely it
and what do you know about japan what do
you know about like the lifestyle over
there you've obviously spent a little
bit of time there before have you i have
yeah i've traveled here with the avs a
couple times and then with the chiefs
once but it's funny when you actually
travel by yourself you know like you
obviously travel with the team and yeah
it's easy because you just you know like
you told me to go
what to do it was like me trying to get
to the airport on the other day
like i was japanese i just i lost
someone like just walking around
um i obviously found my way here which
was fantastic but yeah you take it for
granted i guess you're always traveling
as a team i mean
but yeah as the experience obviously i
love japanese food the japanese people
every time i've been here they're so
welcoming and
very nice and um gotta travel around and
get on the train and go away for some
weekends i've got
robbie robinson cousin he's over here so
catch up with him try catch up with him
and his family a bit and then obviously
heaps of mates are scattered around the
place um so i'm looking forward to
getting there i think it's less
restricting from what it was last year
talking to bears
what sort of restrictions they had on
them so it'd be nice to be able to get
out trip around smash a few ramens
so
i'm currently living off bento boxes so
oh it's true that's shocking yeah yeah
yeah breakfast lunch and dinner is like
a cold bento box oh correct so um it's
like it's not too bad it's not great but
it's not too bad but i said
so i said i'll walk out of here and i'll
go who's the sweet tooth pick me sign
like because there's no weight the only
thing i've got to lift my beard
um and other than that it's pretty much
just just jump on the wall some
i'm not going to come here out in the
greatest neck i don't think
man i don't think they'll be expecting a
massive human when they when they see to
be fair
no yeah we're not going to get out and
smile like i said bento boxes
like i've been very lucky they've sent
me some noodle boxes and stuff and
yeah it's uh
you're nice to get out and actually go
out and get some
proper japanese food
and so you were just dropped off on the
way back from europe so um how was camp
after that or obviously didn't quite
finish the way you guys were probably
hoping for but up until a couple of
weeks ago you guys are on fire which
people are pretty quick to forget yeah
it was it was a big tour like it was
long like
thinking back
when we're in ausd and then obviously
over to the uk and northern hemisphere
tour um like we ended up i think how
many games was it 15 tests throughout
the year and we won both of them like
you said people easy easily forget those
games after a couple losses and it's
like ireland and the french team are
great sides and it's
um it's probably you know like a good
thing for us like it's a good way to
learn how we can get better next year
with a couple losses and it's good how
like how competitive the world rugby is
like he runs the teams are so tight and
close now so
um but it was a fun tour but yeah you
could definitely tell the end of the
boys we're looking forward to sort of
getting back home and like it's a long
time away from family for a lot of those
guys and
particularly have kids as well and
but we had some fun
um aussie was good fun uh played plenty
of golf went to the grand final and then
you jumped on the plane over
over to the uk
and uh yeah we weren't really allowed
out of our hotel that much but we sort
of made the most of what we could do and
but yeah actually it felt like it flew
by quite quickly but as um boys back
home got a seven day quarantine it's
quite funny
like i was leaving and
started into august early september i
was like right
went down and see my parents i was like
right see you in may it's like it's a
lot of times sort of traveling away but
all for the experience it should be fun
mate how hard is it to stay right on
mentally throughout a long tour like
that because obviously all black camps
are pretty intense uh talking to squire
the other week now he talked about just
how mentally draining it is to stay
right on that whole time so a tour like
that must have been i'm pretty tough to
be fully onto it mentally that hope for
that whole tour yeah big time it's um
obviously in the past you know like
you take it for granted when covered
wasn't here you could just sort of get
out of the hotel and go for a walk
around and but you know you're pretty
confined to the team environment the
whole time like he couldn't really
escape it but yeah it does take its toll
but i guess the team itself and the
coaches and management are pretty good
at just recognizing that and giving
giving us sort of time to ourselves when
we need it and um yeah it is tough like
it's it's
you know like when you're in that camp
and you're under that pressure every
week like doesn't matter what team you
play like regardless of what team it is
whenever they play the all blacks they
coming up the blocks flying and you know
if you don't win by a certain amount of
points you know it's you haven't played
that well or if you lose it's like here
you're under under the scope for the
whole week and
so it is pretty um pretty daunting the
whole pressure
of sort of you know trying to escape it
can be quite
hard particularly when you can't sort of
get out and about with
thinking behind an arrow bubble so
um it is definitely tricky like for sure
like in line if i'm saying you know you
don't have times where
it's like
hard to escape but yeah
you find ways you just hang out with the
lads like we play golf on wednesdays and
that's like just a huge you're like it's
like we live for our wednesdays so we
played some epic courses while we're
away thanks to bodhi um
and it's just like that's a good way to
stick just to get out of it get out of
the hotel like we're probably on our
good days like 16 blokes like going out
playing golf
yeah massive crew of us and we we were
fortunate enough to play
we ended up playing on tour
when we were in the uk four ryder cup
courses that have
um they've been playing we've played in
wales county manor um congressional
which is in they've
planned so far ahead so that's in 2037 i
think it's a wee way away
marco simone in italy which is the next
one and
on the french only golf national which
was um played a few years ago so we were
very lucky with the golf
so that was how like we get on golf days
and we just take off for the day how was
your golf game now i haven't seen i
haven't watched you played since since
the new zealand open obviously where you
had the ups and downs
oh that's that's
that started pretty poorly like real
poor and aussie like
but we were playing like so much like we
played so much golf from to a point
where i was just
i don't see the loss was like lost
everything it's funny how like quickly
you can just
then go and lose yourself and like and
all it takes is a couple good shots and
you're like yeah i've got it i know how
to fix that you go back out and it's
shocking game but by the end of the tour
i started to come right got a little bit
better but it is
weird like no i don't think many of us
played to our handicaps while we're away
geordi was probably the closest he's a
gun is jordy the best is he yeah he
plays off a scratch true yeah yeah yeah
see yeah he's a gun he's like he plays
really good really well so
um
but yeah some of the causes we played
were pretty tough so it was um it was a
tough guard to try
now you had to handicap but i'm better
than new zealand anyway
like that was atrocious pressure really
got me there
was that the most nerve-wracking uh
situation you've been in obviously
you're pretty clutch when it comes to
goal kicks and stuff so what's it like
teeing off at the first that in new
zealand
doesn't compare
like not even close like because you
know like rugby obviously you know
you're capable of doing it you know
you've done it before but golf's like
another
and particularly when you're playing
with a pro
yeah it was a disc it was a disgrace my
golf game i nearly gave my clubs to the
elvie to hurt and i'll carry the bag
that was yeah lame worst thing i was on
that the first day we
remember the first time we teed off with
shane warne and i'm ryan fox when the
group behind us oh yeah as soon as we've
about to see off they started walking
down there there would be posse for them
i was like oh no
this isn't going to be good now and it's
funny because people are you know you
used to playing in front of big crowds
it's like now it's not even it's not
even not even close it's not even
comparable
that's classic and you talked about
geordi's uh golf game also he was
playing pretty well on the field as well
so made it pretty hard for you to get
much game time especially in your 15
jersey but how was the tour for you
personally every chance you got you
played well but
um like i said around geordi he was
pretty hard to get out of that 15 jersey
yeah he had
awesome euro lucky
clutch in a few games where he kicked us
to win the game um
he's just so reliable and obviously you
know when you get a northern hemisphere
they play a lot of the kicking game and
a lot of aerial stuff which he's a gun
at so
um yeah he was playing great and um got
a couple opportunities which were
which went not too bad he was the one
against italy probably wasn't as great
as i would have wanted to be as one of
those missings but yeah full
times i sort of got a crack i tried to
you know rip and make the most of it a
couple times enough on the wing which
was interesting yeah um
but yeah like i'm just happy to get on
wherever but
uh it was yeah it was a good good tour
was you know enjoyable but it was uh by
the time it sort of tucked away at the
end it was nice to sort of get get away
from it and finish up mate there's just
so much competition in that squad at the
moment especially around the 10s and 15s
and outside backs it's just so hotly
contested oh man it's um it is like in
particular it's just still guys coming
through the whole time and yeah um
and it's good you know like it creates
good competition throughout the team and
it's like you're never you know resting
on your
capabilities of what you can do you know
you're always going to you know play
well and i guess
you know just that's what you're
training to like be training like a
mother you know it's not going to help
your case either so you've got to be
pretty switched on throughout the week
and then once the game comes around
you've got to make sure you performing
as well so
um oh yeah there's plenty of competition
it's good though it's good um
good competitive rivalry do you prefer
10 or 15 obviously you get asked this a
wee bit but it's probably changed a few
times throughout the years yeah like i
sort of mixed and matched a little bit
and um fifteen you know i enjoyed the
freedom of
just doing your own thing which is fun
but i do and really enjoy 10 as well i
like because you obviously bit more
control and a lot more in the driver's
seat there than what you would be at 15
you sort of get more of a touches on the
ball so i'd say like moving forward like
team's probably a position i want to try
and
focus on and yeah
i think it's a position i'll be playing
over here in japan which would be which
would be good fun and
um
teams there's plenty of good teams
around as well um two blocks
voting right
um it's off at the moment you know
they're pretty big to learn but tough to
pass the moment yeah mate so much
competition but um you talked about
everyone looking forward to getting back
to new zealand for a break and um you've
obviously launched the grins one of the
greatest drinks of all time by the
sounds of it
you've timed that launched really well
give us a little bit of insight and tabs
side hustle started yeah so let me sign
up for the great uh grimm's drink um
probably started like the start of this
year and it's coming it's actually
coming along quite quickly the whole
process and we got um see ants on myself
beaver working torrence and slowly back
home like he is just
foot to the floor like when he's got an
idea or like
something he wants to do he is just he
works himself into the ground so he's
done a lot of work back home and
like even got off the phones on before
and he's in and um packing up uh pellets
probably getting them to send away and
um so yeah it's it started we sort of we
were just
you know we even i did a couple other
things in the past we
we'd invested some money and then we got
chatting about like
how cool would it be to like sort of
have our own drink like we obviously
love the summer time love getting out
and
have a good time with our mates so we're
like it'd be quite cool to you know try
bring out a drink of our own
uh got talking to a few people and then
yeah sort of just started to grow as a
brand and then we got um
a couple of boys to join so alby was
keen to jump on board and obviously he's
mr he's mr summer loves his summer elvis
like he's a very social bloke so he's a
great guy to you know have um in the
crew he'll be um getting the grinch
drink out there plenty over the summer
so
and yeah and then got our flavors sorted
i got the name and then obviously been
fortunate enough with
a lot of very supportive sort of um
you know follow stores around the
country who
jumped at us to jump on board and sort
of stock our product which has been
great so it's in stores
this weekend everywhere pretty much new
zealand so hopefully flies off the
shelves
yeah which has been fun so and it was
actually admit like obviously you know
you have these
things that you put in the pipeline and
it's like a lot of them just get brushed
aside but it was cool to actually see
like i could actually come out and like
boys send us videos at the um at the
factory of the drink getting made up and
getting put in the boxes and seen that's
like picture
the palettes of all the
the grins being boxed off and yeah it
was pretty cool so that's how it sort of
comes that come about it was you know
hopefully just just something outside of
rugby and a different thing we sort of
can
you know put out focus to when we're not
we're not in the footy field hopefully
hopefully it goes all right how'd you
come up with the taste of it was that
you're doing um
yeah like we went in one day to the
factory and like you just do some taste
tests it's funny how they do it like
because obviously you think it's quite a
big process was literally
put it in like a sodastream bottle
carbonate it put a few drop a few
flavors in it so we'd sort of go in
there but oh what about this what about
that i sort of just whip it up in a
couple minutes and then have a taste and
yay or nay and then
yeah so lemon and limes
it was kind of like a we wanted like a
kind of a citrusy one so that one was a
real hit when we took it around and sort
of got a few people to taste it and so
lemon and lime and then
the uh mango pineapple was
pineapple was obviously a flavor or
fruit like that was becoming more
popular alone coming back in like over
hoping to come out and over the summer
so
chuck that in with the mango and yeah
come up with that flavor and it was
pretty delicious as well so
um so far so good had a few
good feedback flavors so
you're an absolutely wizard look at your
guy
actually like i actually just hooks in
and enjoys the grunts oh no a few tessie
boys tried it after the weekend and they
all gave great feedback for it as well
so yeah we've been lucky everyone's been
pretty pretty good with the feedback i
think [ __ ] just let us know and
we'll try and make some adjustments but
i hope hopefully it's not
must be good stuff
anyway i'm pretty keen to hear about the
early days of the young big gym um
obviously good mates with your brother
marty so i know a little bit about your
upbringing but growing up in gore
um give us the rundown of your of your
life back then uh yeah grow up
uh and go just we
obviously always we grew up with dairy
farms so parents of dairy farmers grew
up in this place just below edendale
called sewer downs about 30 minutes out
of the cargo and then moved out to gore
went to school there started like a
primary school about 30 people so that's
pretty um pretty small um he went to
saint peter's college for a couple years
ago uh i've always played rugby since i
was a young fella and um you know i
remember i've seen marty played a lot of
rugby and
my dad played rugby so we watched a lot
of him mum played hockey so we were
constantly once we finished our rugby
we'd head along and watch them do their
thing and
but yeah i remember as a young fellow
like playing down home was just
we play like in the early mornings like
eight nine o'clock and it was you get
you like
hard frost down there like where it's
just it's just
and it's freezing but as a young fella
you know like you just don't really feel
the cold you know like we're playing
like concrete
like
it was literally like concrete like it
was still hard you know you'd finish up
get your pie get your fizzy hit home
just sit in the shower for a while
and just get back out and
do your thing but yeah so that was my
sort of upbringing down home and then
um then moved to
college after that and christchurch is
it true you went up there for a tennis
scholarship is that how you got there
yeah it was like a it was like a sports
scholarship and yeah they kind of like
pinpointed it more on tennis than and
than the rugby aspect yeah
yeah oh i i played a lot of tennis when
i was a young fella probably eight yeah
somewhere around then just started
playing tina so well we're always
encouraged to try and play as new sports
as possible like a summer and winter
sport
it's a gay thing it's a crack and it was
that was good fun it was a lot of
traveling around and
playing a lot of tennis so yeah we're
not there on a tennis scholarship but to
be fair the scholarship only i had the
scholarship the whole time i was there
but tennis only lasted i didn't even
have to last a year to be honest well
apparently you
stopped playing tennis and started
playing for the sea cricket team with
your mates they were filthy yeah i did i
did because
we uh well the tennis they were like
because i started playing at the ml you
know you next play over the winter
and uh i was like well you know i'm
playing rugby like i can't like you know
and then i always see them gonna be one
or the other as well sorry the tennis
got burned
yes i was only playing that for
what have been a year up there and then
yeah when i'm playing i saw i don't know
what else i'm going to do i was like
i remember marty had a few cricket pairs
and a bit round line rounds like i'll
take those so when
played cricket in the social sea team
but the one researcher was still out
there for
six hours of the day and
didn't know much i was too rare that so
you just better than
ran from field from boundary rope to
boundary roping
was old enough like you could start
playing golf so like so i just started
playing golf going to join range once a
week and
had a couple of balls around so yeah
it's pretty crazy so that's probably
when i went up then what ended up being
my main focus was just
jump into the rugby and give that a
crack and i think everyone probably
knows how good you were at schoolboy
level um playing rugby
you were absolutely tearing up the
new zealand scene from a young age so
talk to me a little bit about your
college days playing footy yeah yeah so
um
to be feeling like we moved up there we
didn't like it was more just a different
opportunity or like up in christchurch
and so rugby wasn't like we didn't
really go there for a week and the rugby
at college wasn't like a real strength
of these but dude i'm just small we what
you boys they like we're
tiny
um so you remember kidding up there and
you had like your grading games and that
it's funny so i remember my first
grading game
um
and it was the same weekend as duck
shooting weekend down home and like
being from down obviously south and like
the weekend stops for the duck shooting
so i said to my coach i was like oh like
do you mind if i he'd be on home this
weekend production excuse oh well if you
go down to actually make sure you just
don't come back and play for this team
it's like okay so
play that play um grading games and yeah
i remember we just like see we were just
a bunch of small little white battlers
and always punched fairly well above our
weight but
yeah it was a tough garden tour i guess
you used to play a lot of those teams we
had a lot of the like island boys and
who had obviously matured a lot earlier
earlier than us so
it wasn't until probably under 16s
or they were starting to actually um
front up a little bit better um
so yeah played
i may have played the first routine in
fifth form the fifth seal form we were
always like on the edge of the
semi-finals so never played in the
semi-final but we're close most of the
time
hosts are good after matches you have to
go to some of these places
yeah that was out of that
but now it was fun like the
school rugby business that was good fun
i like you sort of
playing midaro and with the lads and
then play around and just
yeah it was all pretty casual i went
only trained twice a week sort of thing
yeah nowadays you see a lot of those big
big schools they were training like
trains mad health and they trained so it
was pretty casual for us and
um yeah it's good fun playing at the
planet college and and you're not lying
when you say that you're a bunch of
white battlers because one of my
favorite um clips on youtube is you
leading the hacker for the christ boys
yeah your poo carnita word ratio right
up there too it's pretty impressive
it's um
get a lot of compliments for that at the
moment that haka it's
pretty daunting
now i mean like if you for us it was the
captain lead the hacker and like
so yeah in christchurch obviously
every game you do a haka and like you
walk you honestly stand your line and
you walk up when you put your cap down
and it's pretty serious you sort of just
slowly struck back and then
and then jump on and rough into a haka
and
yeah i tell you the stars just
definitely got better i mean was pretty
much straight legging when i was doing
it i mean but
yeah if you want to look at that look at
on youtube it's still there i think
yeah like i said like i was probably
one of the most yeah like we're always
what atlas so there weren't many too
intimidating guys to lead it so you did
it
yeah
and one thing throughout your career um
you've obviously been one of the smaller
guys how often were you told coming
through the grades at school level and
even below like that you were going to
be too small to make it yeah you got
told a little bit like you know like
your size
is going to be of disadvantage of when
you get up or like you you know like
when you play against the big guys you
just
you'll get thrown around and yeah like
so i was always told that but
uh yeah it was probably more just
motivation like you know like just to
prove people wrong and i remember like
growing up like the old man used to
always
you know drill into us like it's
you know like sizes only
you know size doesn't matter like
you know i say like if you check and
somewhere you go you know the bigger
they are the harder they fall
tackle around the boot laces so having a
black wood always be out in the backyard
just
rather than each other rug doing that
stuff so i mean yeah i guess when i
first sort of like got into like the
professional area was kind of like you
know you need to put on more weight you
need to do this you need to do that and
like to a point where like i was just
eating for the sake of eating and
like these days i'd like to have a
protein shake after the gym went having
like net so many calories then i
couldn't even eat lunch and
um
yeah so like i've got like honestly
since i'm left school i've probably put
on like eight kilos like and within like
how many years seven eight years which
is bugger all right like a lot of you
know put some people put that on a
couple years yeah
um
so yeah
just gotta find a way to try try not to
get too beat up so yeah it's funny
because i can't eat like i can eat a lot
when i need to
but yeah just it just falls off me and
that's i'm not worried about these bento
boxes in the next two weeks
i could come out a little racist
did you ever feel internally like it was
gonna potentially be a barrier or did
you never even think that would be an
issue uh
no no i never never really thought it
was going to be an issue like
i saw it as more of like a really fun
challenge like you know like being
smaller you know people can pinpoint you
for just being like now he's too small
running that guy yeah
target that guy which still happens like
you know i'd run at me too if i was
playing against us like how small we are
um see in my early days the tackle steps
weren't too flash so but soon soon got
to learn that um you know it's just as
what it isn't it's a fun challenge to
sort of try and tackle guys who are
bigger than you or
i don't have the size but i guess that
you know the other thing is just
trying to have the speed and agility to
to get around those bigger blokes that's
what i sort of
got to try and do otherwise yeah 100
percent mate you're such a good example
for kids because i know so many kids out
there get told that they're too small to
ever make it professionally but i might
you're like the perfect example of if
you've got speed and agility or i
suppose you've got to be pretty tough as
well you're a pretty tough bugger so
you get you got those attributes and
you can definitely still make it and
dominate at that highest level as well
oh exactly it's um you know like
i guess it's never you know you're never
too small to be able to you can do
anything any size any shape you know so
um
oh it's cool you know if i can be able
to motivate a few more smaller kids to
play rugby and have a crack in it and
you know it's puts a smile on my face so
um yeah anyone can make it
um for sure love that
post college you um went through the
ranks pretty quirky you made new zealand
20s i remember playing you for the
hurricane's development side and oh yeah
you were trying back then and
that was the first time i saw how sort
of tough you were because you were
running into some pretty
big sized adults then
who were playing professional rugby and
um you took a few big hats but mate you
just bounced up and had the next hard
carry and it was i remember thinking
coming off that game like this week it's
tough
yeah it was um everything did come quite
quick and uh which was yeah i was very
lucky i made the 20s of my first year
out of school so i've also moved out to
waikato and
yeah played played made the 20s side
that played in new zealand and
you've been playing you jimmy martin at
wellington game and when we go to iran's
and new plymouth it was uh every time he
gone there he just got threshed and
you know it was quite daunting i
remember the 20s cam was some of the
stuff he had to do was just outrageous
like
you'd go there and it was you know scary
enough but then like from a small school
not really now i'm that much just sort
of jumping in you run around with all
these guys who have been playing uh
the big concept north and
then we had these like this thing called
the longest day where it was literally
like oh how long wasn't that it wasn't a
whole day but like literally we started
in the afternoon and
he just got thrashed the whole day like
running um
circuits we had to run pretty much an
essay on why we wanted to be picked on
the team uh get up in the morning like
registry we ran around this whole field
for like three or four hours carrying
jerry cans just around the field until
they tell us to stop like
just trying to mentally break us pretty
much so
yeah we do all that stuff and then yeah
we played and played in new zealand that
year and i think we made the semis
simi's and we lost to um africa that
year they had a decent side um i think
england ended up winning it actually
but yeah that was that was the start and
then so it was the first real taste of
that international sort of raving
it doesn't didn't disappoint it was um
it was physical especially going from
school rugby when you go straight into
that it's just another level
it was cool like you know you learn from
those experiences which is which has
been great and then how did you get up
to waikato um
always like growing up i always thought
i'd just go back home just like
southlands i was like you know that's
where i've grown up and then funnily
enough i was actually when i was in
christchurch i supported the crusaders
like i've watched the crusaders but
i mean yeah i um i think uh wayne smith
was after the chiefs and he'd got guys
like anton brown and james tucker guys
who would play rugby for christchurch
and he sort of talked and was keen to
sort of have me aligned with the chiefs
um not contracted but sort of like as an
interim we'd go on and train with them
and that
so yeah went up and had a look up there
and initially it was
bayer plenty who offered me a contract
went up and had a look there and i guess
being new like moving away from
christchurch
i was kind of keen to if i could be
based in one place so if i wouldn't had
to train and hamilton with the chiefs
like if i could try and sign with
waikato so i tried to reach out to
waikato to see if there's an opportunity
to play there and then eventually they
yeah they offered me a contract and
um yeah moved straight up after school
so it was bizarre like i just never
thought i'd be up there playing rugby to
be honest got from hamilton
was kind of like obviously when i was in
school in canterbury like they offered
me to stay around sort of a
pud contract and
yes you know canada have got such a
great track record and record of
producing like great players and um like
back then there was a real backlog of
good teams like that round he was like
colin slade tyler blondell dc was still
there tom taylor
richie mwanga was still he just finished
his warehouse like there was plenty of
boards there so i
thought yeah why not so moved up um
moved to hamilton and
you've been there since things been
about eight years now so did you feel
ready going into that environment yeah i
did i like obviously there were some
proud definitely some areas of my game
where i was like you know i could come
like school regulars that's not even
comparable with stuff for airplanes been
going and what a team
so i thought you know there was parts of
it where i was like yeah a little bit
thinking maybe i was underdone but i
sort of always had the attitude of just
you know just would even just chuck to
me or whatever there is like just try
and give it a go
sort of thing so you know i knew it was
going to be challenging and tough we had
quite a young team so it wasn't just me
being there amongst all these old hedge
notes it was pretty of us young boys in
that white kettle team so it was quite
always fun like i said we're a team that
could have
beaten a lot of teams but we're
attaining that you know with not a lot
of experience you know we could easily
lost anyone as well so it was it was
definitely a big learning that first
year i still get reminded now how poor
my tackle stats were someone was trying
to tell me they reckon i was last and
marty was second last apparently the
mckenzie brothers little um last and
second last with jake's flesh
must've been doing well to be worse than
him oh i know sonny a dog
leaking the old leaky bucket
no maybe that's honestly no but you um
you did have summarized that time at
waikato pretty well how you could beat
most teams or lose to most teams on any
day but yeah one game i remember you
guys getting right up for us that ran
for this shield game talk to me about
that one yeah so that was
yeah that it was um like i said like we
did we had a pretty up and down season i
wasn't wasn't that flash at all to be
honest and
um
yeah we caught hawke's bay on the that
week that you know he played three games
in the way yeah we were going until last
game and like like any of the boys like
whenever you're playing your last game
and you know there's like a bit of a big
clear up afterwards like you know you
seem just to get up for him but go down
there just chuck them chuck the ball
around see what happens and
yeah it was it was fuzzy oh like we be
scored a hat trick one of the other
young fellas jordan train it was his
first game
i mean it was his debut game i remember
asking him we're like oh no him like
you know david game like
um you know have you ever played a slave
in the day he goes now i've never played
at night time oh gee i was like okay
he likes the stress and honestly he just
carved up like it was unbelievable yeah
we just got a hat track and we were up
by like
like we're in a position where it's like
no you can't lose and honestly like next
thing you're now able to start coming
back and i'm like oh
i was like surely we don't lose this
yeah it wasn't me today like it was
it was that was good like just how like
our season was pretty average and then
all of a sudden like by winning the ram
food she just
completely turned it around it was
wicked and we had some go in we had some
good old times after it was fun oh i did
and one story that i've heard about is
your famous um golf cart incident
through new world
give me a rundown on that one surely
that's one of the greats yeah
no i said we were um so yes we got back
to hamilton
and now i've been young naive we sort of
just
rounded bee's place near the golf cart
and his garage yeah
and yeah obviously he's wearing it so
and i think it was like 2014 i think if
we were doing it now i'd be mad but we'd
get out like i was in um brent are now
as cricket whites that babe gave me
i was um had an arbor arborist helmet on
um
and uh we jumped in the car anyway
there's like we being myself a couple
others and we drive along and one of the
boys got a shield on the back driving on
the road
and then we
went up to the new world and
wrote a tuner and obviously there's two
stores that into the doors like you
coming one and there's the except the
other yeah and oh my god no idea what
we're thinking
i drove it pulled up drove through one
entrance and then drove out the other
entrance with the golf cart just right
boys away from the boys away from the
shield round
what do you mean well you look like a
sideshow like i'm sitting in my cricket
whites and this big iris helmet on but
yeah but it was um yeah so you see the
next day beef had the keys
um
which is fair enough but that was that
those are the days it was good we were
getting a lot of a lot of people were
sitting there like
toting and yelling
some of the memories we have with that
shield which i'm sure they've got plenty
um it was fun oh man that's absolutely
classic
and then you made your move into the
chiefs pretty much straight away after
that didn't you after your first year at
waikato was it yeah so um 2015 yeah got
was got a contract with the chief so
uh yeah moved in straight after that and
uh
yeah it was um was lucky happened quite
quickly as well and
got a play in the games a few games
quite early when cruds was um coming
back from all blacks duties and yeah it
we're not too bad and sort of it was uh
i was fortunate enough to get
quite a few opportunities that you're
more so just off the bench and
only a couple minutes here and there but
it was it was good fun some weird that
we're
looking back on the team we had now like
it was we had some some some serious
athletes in that team and our coaches we
had two were
world-classed as we were looking looking
back on it yeah now you're so humble you
absolutely carved up your day but i
remember it you were you were running a
muck for a debut oh i remember my day
was the blues going off in auckland and
to fear how got a few decent towers out
outside me i had sunny outside me
ended up obviously about kicking a few
goals so yeah it could have been worse
but yeah it was nice to be able to start
off on a good note i remember swanny was
in the team that year too now i actually
think he got robbed he didn't start like
remember playing the preseason games and
it's like sonny was obviously played a
bit more than me and
he had a good preseason better than what
i did yeah anyway and then they backed
me to start in the first game i'm like
oh
that's funny yeah i'm sorry
got lucky there but no it did start not
too bad i mean once crowds come back so
like said like to sit on the bench for a
while and then later in the season ended
up getting a couple games at 15. so
we're living with marty while you're up
there yeah we lived uh with mitch
croswell oh yeah
yeah yeah it's three of us so
yeah we live we all floated together and
just played in hamilton and
it was good fun it was good fun he sort
of sort of been around the traps a bit
he was back and forth up in hamilton for
a while then went down the south and
then come back up here up hamilton
one story that i it's come up a few
times in the podcast is
your famous prank on whopper and tojo
about the mongrel mob leaving that note
yeah
talk to me how this one happened from
your side of the story
yes obviously your brother
toei and what live together and beth um
and uh
we i think it was the night after we
we'd massage at the chiefs headquarters
and
come outside and i've got all this
rubbish in my back seat in my truck
now it's like a towie and wiper just has
been had a massage i was like yeah key
suspects so anyway we're like what do we
do what do we do so and we almost
remember what we used to come in and be
like oh this is just um guys around the
corner who are in the manga mob and they
just sit out in the garage and you know
try and wave at them we're not when i
can and they were blind i was like
alright we should go around there and
just
write a note and leave it on their door
and just say like
you know
stop waving us so pretty much tonight
was like tell your fat curly headed
friend stop waving at us when he drives
past
he goes otherwise
you guys will have you guys will pay for
it
anyway
we will we come to training the next day
and i've never seen tony so quiet like
he's just like walking around he's
walking around
and said what were like what what's
wrong with towing he goes yeah yeah you
wouldn't believe it he goes got this
note on our door from the muggle around
the corner
and he goes toe is [ __ ] himself
because biff's been ringing and bringing
him up no okay we've got to move we've
got to move
and big laughter like he's like oh you
know like he goes if that was me back
home he goes if i didn't wave i'd be
pissed off he goes i'm waving to them
every day and they just never wave back
to me
and so and obviously honestly we need to
tell him because i've never i've never
seen tony like it like to joselana
usually you know gets puts the pranks on
him you know we we tell them pretty
quickly like sorry boys that was us more
probably for the fact that poor old beth
back at home was probably just
sitting at the looking at houses so she
can move to so
yeah yeah we always you know try to get
back at each other oh mate that's one of
the great [ __ ] i love it yeah
and the other one was when you guys were
going around to um partners do and um
yeah
yeah yeah you're escaping you're pretty
early give me the run down this one
surely that's not true i know you handle
yourself yeah it's not it's not it's not
it is kind of but it's not um yeah we
partners yeah apart so i went with marty
and and um
like oh come around early like come
around for a few drinks early and we're
like yes sweetheart and that kind of was
like
probably not a great thing i mean anyway
we dressed up
as these tennis players rolled in so
he's like oh we'll start playing some
darts it's like yeah sweet so we're
playing darts like the highest number
last number last night i missed the
drink yeah so that was
yeah that was punishing and then we
played like
the [ __ ] game with the cards you
know you're like if you've got the
cardio yeah you're two drinks and you're
like [ __ ] but i was so worried
because tojo can drink like a fish that
like i knew like
two beers for him was nothing so i'd be
like i'll just stack my beard up i'm not
gonna i'm not even gonna school it on
you
anyway he got pretty rolled and i've
ended up
i remember
leaving like i walked out of the back
room like jumped over the fence and
taken off
in terms of stay they reckon i did the
[ __ ] house shuffle because like now the
bathroom door was locked we couldn't get
it and you must have jumped the other
windows so
but no i didn't but yeah i mean i
learned after that i was like
like there's one guy you don't want to
keep up with or try drink with that's
that's tojo he's a menace
so good and your form on the field
obviously um especially the last couple
years has been on absolute fire you've
um won that many games for them over the
last few years you come up clutch maybe
five or so games in a row last year it
was it was an incredible streak so mate
talk to me a little bit about your time
on the field playing for the chiefs yeah
chase we've had some epic seasons like
seeing like that first time when i
started out like some of the blokes with
their team with
a gun you know like we
some good seasons we kind of always sort
of made sort of see these quarters never
we never never got to a final um that's
the same this year was the first one
i've ever actually played in like in my
life first of all i've played in so um
yeah it's an epic club to play for like
the fans like obviously reality like
really good not not a lot of
people love coming up to hamilton and
playing really like but yeah like his
first couple years were a good good
learning character it was good like
playing when you first start because
like
so people don't know you that much so
you sort of get away with a bit more but
like as soon as a few more years i've
played like
the opportunities just
so few you know like there's not as many
the holes aren't as big people were
trying to shut you down so it probably
took a while for me to learn about that
just thinking it was always just going
to happen and
you know like you know years or like
games where just stuff would happen
easily and then the next game you know
you'd better and you'd wonder why so
learned like for a while like my
maturity of a like my game management
sometimes i'd be running up from
everywhere yeah and like you know
whereas i should be kicking that so i
feel like definitely growing in that
area but probably the uh the toughest
year we had was
that 29 2019 year and that's the year i
got uh yeah it was next year i got
injured too so
um that was a tough year feel sorry for
like
the lands like you know
for how hard you try like just nothing
was happening like and until you go
through that like as a team you don't
realize like you looked at like like
teams for example say like the blues in
the past like had those sort of years
and until you're actually in the
position it's like it's not as easy as
you think you know like yeah it doesn't
matter what was right or what happened
it was like we're always like you know
on them on the losing side of things
like
whereas this year or like um
yeah this year like the bounce of the
ball was just
you know would go away a bit more which
was which was effort like it was just
like winning that game our first game we
beat the canes
like just that feeling of winning and
like once you start winning you just get
like you know you're such more positive
it's like it's convey just like just a
positive energy around the club and
then all of a sudden like you know like
said like ball that wouldn't bounce away
in the past will start to bounce away
and those laughs and it just makes going
over yeah that their health like it it's
just it makes something it makes it so
much more enjoyable you know like lads
are just having heaps of fun and and
that's that so they like down at the
trainees each week like he runs just up
for zen
so yeah it had some pretty good runs
this year and some pretty pretty cool
moments like it's it's cool to be able
to
you know nail kicks
for your team and stuff like that it's
pretty cool feeling being able to do
that
um you know seeing what what we've gone
through in the past and where we are now
which is great and yeah it's it's i've
got some epic club to be a part of it's
you know it's
it's a club always
hold dear to my heart and always want to
play for so what is your mindset lining
up these uh match winning kicks um it's
kind of like yeah i guess
just like a
you know you don't give a [ __ ] sort of
attitude you know like you just
that's how i sort of try and visualize
it um because so many times you can sit
over a cat
and you just
overthink it you know
like an oil it's so easy like you just
it's just a kick you know it's a
straight kick
just kick it so
kind of attitude i try and have is
just trying not to overthink it and
those like there's a kicker like you
know it's cliche but like those you know
moments you sort of live for you know
like if you can sort of hero zero you
know you either make them or you don't
but
um
yeah just try and not really care too
much about it it goes over it goes over
and
yeah just lucky enough just feel them we
went down the middle which is
which was cool yeah mate it's easier
said than done just just kick it
oh man it's like you sit over like you
sit on a kick
it's been like when you go to the
driving range when you you're playing
golf like the driving range like you hit
it man and as soon as you get out and
play you play around you're terrible you
know so
um yeah you just got to get up there and
just give it give it a snot how good and
also your all black screw obviously you
went through the went through to the all
blacks pretty quickly as well so that
was pretty rapid rise as well i think it
was the following year from your chief's
debut but um talk to me about the first
time you went into that environment and
what that was like for you yeah 2016. it
was um what first time i made it was the
it was the june series actually we were
playing wales and um
[Music]
remember
where i got the call when we
just finished playing the warrior towers
in sydney got the quarters out made it
and i was you know fizzed up and anyway
we
went to camp hit our three weeks and um
we won the series after two games and
then the last game you know we i hadn't
played it all and then the last game the
name naming the team on a tuesday
anyway i'm like listening to the team
and
all these names are getting read out who
haven't played pretty much pretty much
everyone who didn't play it was good
name i was like here we go here we go
boys i'm going to get named here 22-23
it's 23. no not my name i was like oh
okay
so everyone got picked to play
that's serious about me and like
obviously they might you know it was
probably
more a learning experience for me to go
out and play
and i'll just see what it was like in
the environment anyway tomorrow like
sort of chat into the coaches and they
said oh like we just thought you could
have been
a lot better with
how you prepared throughout the week
and obviously you know the all blacks
you sort of have they have like a
prepare to play mindset um you have your
week plans you plan out each each
training of what you're going to do
and whereas so once i didn't get named i
was like well i'm not playing i was just
gonna help other boys like yeah so
if someone needed high balls i'd just go
kick them balls someone needed
tackle practice i'll just go and hold
the tackle peg because obviously
in the past that's just
what i'm what i knew like
if i'm not playing why would i just
do my stuff i'm better off helping
someone to prepare as play so i've soon
learned that you've got to be a bit
selfish on um preparing yourself um so
that was a bit of a change up so yeah
but that was the first time i made it
and
um and then later on that year i didn't
make the championship squad but got
called in and played
debuted in um argentina that year
against okay it's the only team so
it was fun and appearance coming and
watching it and some family friends and
a good mate and came off like 20 minutes
ago and usually the boys are
on fire and
attack and i think we're on d the whole
time we've been trying
uh
pretty much just on d the whole time
that's what he got and scotty got yellow
cards that didn't help um but yeah the
debut game was a bit of a blur i don't
remember too much but to be honest apart
from just the trial in them to this year
and we did you feel comfortable at that
level you spoke that you did feel
comfortable playing for waikato and the
chiefs so what was it like at the all
black level was it next level up or did
you did you feel comfortable there no it
was definitely a next day like it took
me a bit to sort of definitely took me a
while to
not so much gain confidence but still
just get used to the whole flow of
international rugby like yeah how how
much quicker it was the physicality of
the whole
whole game and
see it it definitely took me a while
like i guess it's like anything like
this time in the saddle just gives you a
bit more confidence you know and
um but yeah i'm in the first two
two sort of game there's argentina and
italy i was like a couple of times i
just remember just running around like a
cubeless chuck like just
not lost but like kind of like
that once it was i guess because i'm so
used to playing at super and miter where
you might have been able to get away
with it like getting snatched around
just
you're running backwards you're running
sideways it's like
blokes want you to run forward so soon
learn
soon got to learn through that a bit
better so yeah it definitely took a
while like um it was it was definitely a
hard one to get used to and one moment
that jumps out at me about your all
black career is your injury coming
leading up to the 2019 world cup uh how
hard was that to deal with for you
yeah it was
it was it was tough you know like i've
touched wood i've always been um
pretty fortunate with injuries and
uh
never really had an issue and i remember
the whole incident uh swanny put a kick
out and i was chasing it and
um oh teddy black's on the court i'm
catching i'm trying to like step and
keep tackling my knees just buckled out
underneath me so
uh oh yeah it was tough like being told
and then knowing like
not being able to be back for the world
cup which is obviously something you're
trying aiming towards and um it was
tough like having to rehab and train and
like you take for granted that all that
little stuff like being able to train as
a team like
um just going into training seeing the
lads every day and
yeah i wouldn't say i'm like a person
who um
doesn't appreciate things but when
you're in moments like that like you you
soon
you know miss the little things that
you take for granted each day you know
so
um
it was definitely a good learning
experience but not not on time and not
something you want to go through at all
but um yeah it was tough watching home
definitely
tough watching from home
matt did you always feel like you're
going to be able to get back to the same
explosiveness and same speed and all
that throughout the whole rehab yeah
yeah like i was always pretty
complicated really crew looking after me
and you know you do heaps of heaps of
like rehab like one-legged stuff and
that to get it back and obviously
nothing that guys have done in the past
like heaps of people who had done it
reached out to me and said look there's
anything you need or any advice just
just reach out which was great and yeah
i never
had any doubt
that it was going to come back and it
wasn't going to you know i was going to
lose anything like that like um i think
i
believe i still got the same speed i had
when i left and
um
yeah like i said like just training by
yourself by having to learn how to do
that was that was the hardest thing
trying to get back so
and it's good you know like motivation
to be like
right you know it's a new year and the
timing of the whole situation like i did
my acl
2019
and then usually they say nine to 12
months
and the ninth month was pretty much a
week before the first round of super so
kind of worked out there was no need for
me to rush to get back i could just take
my time down the rehab
which was which was good um so yeah it
managed to
nail that off and now it feels really
good now obviously it's not not the same
there it used to be but it's it's fine
and so you've got your body's feeling
good you've got no niggles yeah yeah
and uh
top shape at the moment you wait for the
swamp watch need to hide in the next
next two weeks
i hate them okay it's a shocker yeah
but yeah now i'm feeling good it's nice
this two weeks are kind of
you'd rather not be doing quarantine but
it's good just just chill out and um you
know obviously it's been a long season
so
and usually we're in a break this time
of year with the summer period which
i'm not this year but um it's yeah i'm
looking forward to obviously what's
coming ahead with the japanese season
wrapping into that but feeling fresh
mate
um hopefully stay that way throughout
the season yeah yeah and so what are
your plans going forward you obviously
got your japan contract now and then the
goals to obviously get back into the all
blacks next world cup is is that pretty
much as far as you've thought yeah i
think yeah for me it is yeah so oh um
obviously
the japan thing was you know like a
something new just so try something
depression um hopefully rejuvenate
myself by coming back into my back new
zealand and
um and then yeah hopefully
hopefully i can make the all that squad
during the championship obviously you
have to play a bit of my team cut first
and whether they still want me then so
hopefully fingers crossed
that's the custom and then yeah
hopefully a world cup in france so 23
will be will be epic to be a part of
obviously
the old uh
stone and the shoe not been able to play
in the last one so cool to be able to
nail it off and make that squad to be
great no doubt
and give us a little bit of run down on
your plans plans after 40 going forward
what if what have you got sorted just
going to retire on grins and
make 11 sip and sipping grins on the
beach
yeah i think so mate oh um
now
i guess um hopefully it can still take
away this take away rugby for a few few
good years but
you know obviously post rugby um
i haven't nailed down exactly what i'm
going to do um
yeah i'll be lying if i said i had
something now right now to be honest um
obviously got a lot of hobbies
that i love doing but um in terms of the
interests outside
which i can see what's happening i don't
know we were still grim screams could be
still if we still got it stuff and
running i might be down
man on the ground getting through stores
uh
who knows he knows what we're doing golf
tours hello all right celebrity guys i
don't know if i'm i i don't know if i'll
be behind a desk
enough i'm the smartest cookie i don't
know from the smartest cookie for that
i thought you're going to be behind the
cart with your brother no he's just got
his real estate ticket so i might just
be his um pa
just sit in the office and
get him to give him some real estate
here
today
how does it work yeah yeah whatever it
will be no doubt you will absolutely
kill it but as always we've gone to our
instagram for some questions and make
very popular guests like yourself you've
come up with plenty
so many questions were about this
question
would you ever play for the stags we got
this one maybe 10 plus times there's a
lot of stag fans wanting you back down
there playing with your brother
yeah yeah i definitely would yeah long
story short i think it's um
you know it's home like it's where i
grew up um i played a lot of like age
grade or
um weight grade rugby and southland so
uh you know a lot a lot of a lot to that
problem so it'd be somewhere i'd like to
play
down the track in the future um
it's you know like i said it's it's home
where it's where i grew up but then also
like where i am now and hamilton with
waikato it's partly home as well um it's
where i've been the last few years and
now
the opportunity i've given me has been
the outstanding in that great
province and proud province to be a part
of so but yeah i will hopefully get a
maybe play a game or two down and south
before i finish i'm just not sure when
you oh man that's gonna have the stag
fans excited
okay next one let's got this one a few
times people obviously loved um the
prank done on you um so what was going
through your mind during the prank when
you had your call from woop oh my there
was gold all day that was um i remember
so
last night
um
i remember you bringing it again um
oh you were going to do the shoot by
when you're like you know you want to be
known
but then i was like no i've heard of
people doing like
you know like it's not that people
haven't done their stuff but i was like
oh it's just a bit weird and then you're
like yeah well we're gonna have like you
know watermelons um
blueberries you know there's a little
frozen hearths like this
and then i remember someone who was it
said they'd been pranked by you like a
week or two earlier and i was like geez
that
that
um
voice sounds familiar
and then yeah we might click that
like oh yeah
yeah because it's funny because
there's the whoop like honestly i was
pumping it everyone like i was telling
people like and i wasn't even like
obviously
sponsored or anything like that they
weren't giving me anything yeah which i
was didn't expect to get anything but
but i was just telling the boys i was
like i've got this whoop and honestly
like you need to get onto those
best things since sliced bread like the
easiest thing ever and so then when you
rang up i was like oh yeah here we go
yeah that was that was gold man it was
gold oh but the best thing is that they
did come to the party hey they did end
up spotting yeah
they did like someone's seen them and
they're like oh that's a good laugh it
didn't last too long though so i was
more than happy i'm more than happy to
pay for my um pay for my food uh so
yeah still gonna i think i've got a few
people on board from it so yeah
that's just that's just a great company
oh man that was one of the greatest i
love that one crack me up okay next one
is a as a story from your brother about
when you broke his nose with your
motorbike helmet because he tried to
kill a hedgehog with a rock give me the
run down on this one
yeah i was um
yeah when we were we were real young i
think we might have been
coming here from school
we stopped at the kettle stop and then
the kettle stopped there was this
hedgehog
and i was quite oh i was like he was
just one past he's getting his stones
he's just different at this point he'd
choke and i'm like
talking about he's like pretty much he
doesn't deserve that like you can't be
done that time and then it's like
grabbing him anyway he's got me a
chokehold and i've got my motorbike
helmet and i've just gone like
smacked his nose and yeah that's that's
that's broken now so over there over the
headshot
and the thing is that hedgehog he
wouldn't have been able to get out of
that and then um kettle stopped so he
would have died not too long after the
poor thing
yeah
was there heaps of buffer between you
two growing up obviously you guys are
both pretty angry man yeah he was they
were like we were we were we were good
but they were definitely where a little
bit of the photons like where and like
the thing was marty is like
he would always have the last say like
regardless like so every time i'd do
something or he'd done something to me
so i'd get him back and you know like
that's you'd say even but then he'd need
to get back to you so every time i'd
like run out of the house and i'd be out
of the house for like a good while
because i go back in there yeah because
he's mad like some of the stuff he'd do
yeah we had sweden we definitely had
some of the foes i remember once around
wanna kearney's he was gonna take this
is our stupid stories he was gonna place
the jet ski and take it away for the
weekend i was like you're not taking it
anywhere like you're leaving it here
anyway he's um i've been at him and the
next thing he's just clocked me in the
face anyway parents come home and they
go oh what's happened to you and mate's
going oh no i chucked the cricket board
as i
said he's got a black eye
there's stuff like that where you know
we'd always
you just run with it you'd run with the
cricket ball story just run with that
and just like it's not worth it just run
with it but yeah now we're a bit better
now we've matured a bit now so
that would be all good
okay next one fastest all black over 100
meters
uh rico you aren't is it easy is it oh i
reckon so yeah he's rapid eye
yeah he's quick like once he gets gone
yeah he's he's rapping where would you
be on the rankings top five
um
i don't know where i would be
two no no no no i was in the top five
would be doing really very well i'd say
all those wingers stuffed uh rapid bodhi
um yeah that will pretty quick my my
best is probably just over a short
distance start to fade getting late in
100 meters are you one of the quickest
over 10 oh yeah like top five maybe um
again like
race uh has maggie like now he's quite
hit now he's like rapid just like real
like his first couple of steps like he
just hits away pretty quick i heard
richie's pretty quick over 10 is he yeah
and lasher yeah he's real quick yeah
he's quick over 10 so yeah
serious wheels on that side okay mate
last question i know you've got to get
to japanese so um best piece of advice
you've received in your career uh best
piece of advice would be um it's
probably like advice like not so much
like one bit of advice but like always
make most of every opportunity that
you're given like
um
i felt like growing up we were given a
lot of opportunities as kids and you
know like when you give them those
opportunities you don't want to let
people down or you want to make sure you
make the most of them and so
um you're never looking back saying you
know what if what if i did that better
so
um
you know any opportunity you get make
sure you put your best foot forward um i
think that's the most important thing um
and if it's an opportunity you know
you've got to make sure you enjoy it as
well
um there's a lot of times you can do
things for the sake of doing it but
um yeah i think that would be my best
advice make most of y'all tune in have
some fun enjoy it
i love that and you've certainly lived
by that as well mate you've made the
most of every opportunity and you
obviously have a lot of fun doing it
always got a smile on your face but
my absolute honor to have you on the
podcast mate really appreciate you
giving up your time over there while
you're in quarantine and i'm coming on
the podcast it's been awesome to go
through your journey um and mate i love
watching you play like i said mate
you're a inspiration for all the little
men out there in the world so um keep
doing your thing keep enjoying it keep
getting me a heap of fantasy ready
points by breaking all your tackles and
playing your game but i really
appreciate you coming on legion thank
you thanks mike
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you